Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in the final verse of surah al
chapter number 73 verse number 20
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala out.
Let's see what he says.
[Silence]
Hence recite
what is easy
and what is
appropriate
for you. Now this recitation here the
scholars of mention two meanings
to the intention behind the word
recitation
in surah m.
Notice that
the opening verses
they are speaking about recitation
reciting the Quran or speaking about
praying.
Which one is it?
Speaking about
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala says
he says stand in prayer in the night.
And so at the end of the chapter, he has
abregated Ness the obligation of prayer
at night
and made it from obligatory to
highly encouraged.
And that is because the five daily
prayers have now abregated
making at night and abregated
the
at
the time of at the time of
after sunset. This was the way that
salah was first as we mentioned at the
beginning of this chapter.
And so we know that this
Ness, this abrogation
came
after the five daily prayers were
legislated and took the place of the
obligation of making
the five daily prayers
as they are today.
These were
made obligatory.
on what event? During which event?
And
in the correct opinion
was which year?
Come on guys. Huh?
Second year.
the second year after hij or the second
year after prophethood.
Yeah. To to be to be
honest the second year after
prophethood. So when he was 42 years old
this is the opinion of
you mentioned two years before hijra. So
11 years after prophethood.
Okay. So
it was the 10th year after hijra or
10th year after prophethood three years
before hijra right on the heels of hus
and husen was which year?
The nth. The 10th was
the the five obligatory prayers are
obligated.
He is sent back to earth with that
obligation
and
now becomes something that is highly
recommended. Okay. So when Allah says in
this verse,
recite of the Quran what is easy for
you, what is convenient for you. Is he
speaking about recitation
or is he speaking about salah?
These are the two opinions that the
scholars of mention.
holds the view that this is speaking
about recitation of the Quran because
that's what the wording says.
However, we know that sometimes Allah
will use the word recitation
and really what is intended is what?
Salah. So for instance,
so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala places a
specific emphasis on the Quran, the
recitation of the Quran at what is he
speaking about here?
Huh?
He's speaking about but being that there
is no such thing as salah without Quran
it becomes a necessary component.
Therefore, we can refer to the whole by
one of its necessary parts.
for instance,
Hajj is
standing on is if a person just stands
on alone,
is that Hajj? Of course not. Their Hajj
is invalid according to the consensus of
the however standing on is so
emphatically important
as a component of Hajj that we can refer
to Hajj by calling it what? Standing on
recitation of Quran in salah is such a
necessary component of salah that we can
refer to all of salah with just what?
With just recitation of the Quran.
Listen to this hadith. How many of us
have heard this narration? It's a
narration of
it's what? It's a
where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
I have divided
I have divided prayer between myself and
my servant into two equal halves.
And for my servant what he has asked
we've heard this narration before. What
is he speaking about? I have divided
salah between me and my servant. He's
speaking about
So here we have referring to salah
by calling it Quran and we have
referring to parts of the Quran by
calling it salah because they come
together and salah really what is salah
what's the point of salah it is all
formed around the recitation of the
Quran
think about it the First thing you do
Allahbar
you initiate then you begin to recite
the Quran.
Then after reciting the words of Allah
verbatim
Allah and you go into bowing and you say
and then you rise.
Allah answers
those who praise him
and then you go into sujud and you ask.
Sujud comes after recitation.
Comes after recitation.
All of salah is built and based and
formed around what? Around the
recitation of the Quran.
And so
this is one opinion.
Also we have in the Quran Allah refers
to salah by calling it.
He refers to salah by calling it.
He says
with those who are bowing. What does
this mean?
Right. But is there such a thing as
without?
No.
kind of in English, if I say,
"I just bought a new set of wheels."
What does that mean?
Huh? Who where are the hip hip you
know, slick talkers? I bought a new I
bought a new set of wheels.
Huh? Bought a new car. Why? Why is it a
car? Is there such a thing as a car
without wheels? that is a necessary
component of a vehicle, right?
Therefore, I can refer to the whole
vehicle as that component is that
necessary component.
Or for instance,
a person
would
refer to a house, an entire house, and
say, "I bought a twobedroom." What is a
two-bedroom? Is there only two bedrooms
in it? No bathroom, no kitchen, no
living room, no foyer, no no porch, no
anything, no driveway. No, but there is
no such thing as a house without what?
Without a place to sleep. That's the
basis of what you're buying a house for,
as shelter for yourself.
And so this is commonly used in the
Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
Allah sees you amongst those making
meaning what?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam asked
one of his companions. He said ask me
for anything you want.
And what did he ask for?
Jenna,
I have no desire other than to be your
companion in paradise.
He said the prophet said
he said so help me help you
with lots of sujud. Meaning what? Lots
of what? Salah. Make additional salah at
night. That's the point. But there's no
such thing as salah without sujud.
The second opinion is that this is
speaking about recitation in salah.
Recite that which is accessible to you.
what is convenient of the Quran meaning
in salah.
Therefore, we know that there is a bare
minimum of of recitation in salah. What
is the bare minimum of recitation in
salah?
Fat. Yes. And this is the opinion
of the majority of the scholars. And
this is the correct opinion due to the
authentic
and very clear narrations of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam where he says
anyone who prays without reciting in his
prayer
then his prayer is invalid.
So this means that the bare minimum of
recitation in salah is
anything beyond that is additional and
anything beyond that is
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then goes on
to say
he gives now three commands. Number one,
he says, "And all of you establish
prayer
and give zakah
and lend Allah
a
good loan or a good lending which we
will get to. A salah,
this word salah, who can tell me what it
means in the Arabic language? A salah.
A dua. Okay, good. So in the Arabic
language is actually what? Dua. Okay.
What is the origin or the root word of
salah? Good topic, isn't it? What did
[Arabic recitation]
the root word of salah does not come
from
meaning connection, connectivity or to
tie things together.
Rather it comes from a
what is a in the Arabic language?
Ai
to burn something. Yes, that is the
meaning of comes from the root word
and it shares the root word of sali.
Aali in the Arabic language is not just
to burn something.
It is to envelop something in fire
entirely without leaving out a single
bit of it.
Where do we find this word in the Quran?
Throughout the Quran. Right.
Right. This is
That in the Arabic language is to take
something and envelop it in fire
completely.
And that is why this word.
Whenever you see in the Quran that
whoever this kind of person
or
when this wording is used it is only for
kufur.
Why is the Muslim even a Muslim who goes
to the hellfire
ever entirely enveloped in fire?
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that
[Silence]
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us in the hadith of annis that
Allah has prohibited upon the fire the
places of sujud on a Muslim's body
what a person uses to make sujud those
seven points that will never be touched
by the fire of hell
and so a believer is never enveloped in
fire.
[Silence]
,
and so the question here is why does
salah, which is dua, the Arabs use it,
dua. Why does it share a commonality
with burning something? What's what's
the commonality there?
When we say in Arabic
mean
for
[Silence]
men.
Alsaz,
[Silence]
Mafaz.
Allah
sal
So the Arabs in their Arabic language,
they sometimes describe something with
its opposite.
Why? To show that this thing has an
immediate effect on that opposite. So
for instance, a salah shares a
commonality with a which is to burn
something entirely. Why? Because by
making salah a person will exempt
himself from being burnt.
When a person makes salah,
this person is burning and purifying
himself from the sin that would end up
burning him in the hereafter. And this
is why the scholars tell us in the
correct opinion that a salah shares its
origins and etmology with burning
something.
Why? because of the effects that a salah
has on a person's sins. Also because of
the difficulty of salah.
It's holding your hand to a fire.
Right? When you stand for salah,
you are reciting what you should be
and then you are praying and begging to
Allah
to make better what you are.
And so if a person really takes his
prayer seriously, it will be very
difficult for him. It is something that
is not easy to maintain your focus to
maintain. It's trying to hold your
hand over over an open fire. And so the
Arabs referred to
as
this is the meaning of salah. Allah says
establish prayer. He didn't say just
pray. He said establish prayer. The
difference between pray and establish
prayer is the one who prays is the one
who does who who you cannot
linguistically say he didn't pray. But
the one who establishes prayer is
someone who fulfills its conditions, its
pillars, and its obligations. He
establishes it.
As for the one who prays
in the Quran, this is usually the
descriptions of the hypocrites
in the Quran.
[Silence]
and so the language of the Quran most
usually there are exceptions
Allah
in the end of the verses.
This is a rarity.
However, the most usual description of a
person who prays a prayer
is usually given to the
in the Quran. As for the believers, they
are described not as being people who
just pray. They are people who establish
prayer. They embody it. They go to the
epitome. They epitomize their prayer.
Inshallah, we will pick this up tomorrow
night with a zak and loaning Allah.
Allah says, "And those who loan Allah a
good loan." We will discuss that wording
[Arabic recitation]
so
because it was going to be weird
but